hey guys we're gonna watch kingdom
episode four today youtube energy
activating now hey let's go ahead and
hit that like button
and losing energy subscribe and click
that notification bell to get a notified
sincerity or our next reaction goes so
far
right now
you know what else guys hey full length
watch alongs where you sync up with a
time code as well as reaction highlights
for kingdom but also a bunch of other
shows are over our patreon page come
over and check those out also big thanks
to the boys at prepper for cutting down
these highlights let's jump in let's do
it
is that good thank you you're welcome i
just realized kingdom
can be a double meaning
is that so
yeah how's that like that kingdom come
oh yeah i will be done or like an
ascension to
something death deep
like this king is dumb for thinking he
could prolong his life this way
yours is better
i didn't finish my thoughts
no you're all going to die down here
yeah
just decapitate all of them
oh prince you are awesome
back to where it all started could there
be some some hiding in there
i wouldn't put it past him at all
there's got to be a few
i don't know
oh no
[Applause]
i'm going to come back in time and vote
for you
not that that's how a monarchy works but
should have stabbed stabby
swords at the ready
to do that shot
i felt that over here
so you are such a badass the baddest ass
removing the head or destroying the
brain
get up get up no no
oh don't don't
don't don't
headphones man
i hope there's a zombie on this boat has
been a movie like that zombies on a boat
are they transporting the king emperor
i don't think so i think he's back at no
why would they be doing that oh
she salvaged his body now
wow
holy crap dude what a great shot they
use great use of aerial shots on this
show
all you lazy-ass old people the kids
sit back while everybody else does the
hard work
you just
[Music]
find a dead human body
and mix up
[Laughter]
being so stern you knew this prince guy
was too good to be true
that's what he's going to do
[Laughter]
should i kill myself with this
oh he's gonna be like i can follow him
yeah
[Music]
they start tearing
[Laughter]
oh my god he's a former hit man he is
unusually skilled yeah at like
all things physical
my god are they rising earlier is is the
fog like blocking out the sun enough
that
you know what
you dicks
[Music]
oh what a crock of [ __ ] yeah
oh come on
he just saved all these people no after
how hard they all worked
oh
man what the hell
teamwork
oh wow he's way more efficient than i
thought
i was like
this least moves as possible occam's
razor fighting
[Laughter]
yeah buddy
i ain't gonna you know we'll just get
rid of all these gonna feed him to him i
guess
man's gotta eat
wake him up
wow
and then behead you
[Music]
[Music]
it's quite a game of thrones going on
people man people
they are just
the worst aren't they
human beings
are disease
i can't
these are my favorite uh versions of
the zombie stuff
it's funny because the show essentially
does um
the zombie genre
but it lets it live within all the roots
of like a historical korean drama yeah
that's what's so clever about it because
like the you see especially this episode
really puts reminds you again
at the forefront that
the humans are really the bad guys
in this case this is their fault this
happened um
they're still fighting over kingdoms and
[ __ ] and couldn't give two shits about
the people
while this rabid disease is infecting
their lands
and it came about
due to their attempts to prolong the
king's life for a machination of you
know political power grabbing
yeah
i like the uh i really like the first i
like i mean i like the whole thing for
sure
but everything about the prince and
when he does have what i imagine could
sound very corny in english
what is it like
these people you're not gonna leave
these people i am different
i'm not like them but i don't know man i
had like uh he's got a little misty-eyed
motivational
spirit rising in me
along with some drool
pretty sure i had some drool
i was like i was so so into that moment
because he like we know that's
where it was going
is that the people who really need the
most help he's going to be the one to
actually help them
and he puts them before himself
constantly
uh it's not really he you see that even
though the first episode showed you that
he did commit some form of treason
uh that it was not in the in the vein of
uh you know
greedy desire for the throne he's not
conniving yeah
yeah so you see here that he he's a man
of his word in that regard and how he is
going out there
and every aspect and like he'll he goes
to the back of the line to make sure
they're gonna get through those gates
and i love seeing how they're all
very much you know like they have the
great moment where he they do like thank
him and he doesn't he's not even like
you're welcome my people yeah he's just
like hey let's help them out we gotta
feed these guys now and then you know
you got your uh the young shin
character
who when we first met him he he he's
really uh opposes the way the kingdom is
run and and opposes the
king the way
the government is and treats them so i
love that little look that he had there
where he does help out the children you
see how the children even them were like
we deserve to die
kill us i'm sorry for hitting you and
he's just like here's some food
chill out you know kids go have fun
and then you see that look he has and
now look you're you you immediately know
okay he's gonna follow him this guy
really is different i'm on board now he
even gives him a chance
when they
he like he gives him a chance when when
the arrows and
when they're i forget what the name of
their little village is called but when
they're being attacked and then the
people are dying which was so sad but
when they're dying you know young shin
looks up at him and it's like it is your
fault but you got to stand man up he's
not he doesn't like turn his back on him
and is like
screw you i hope you think or something
you know
yeah he he it's like he's
he's informed enough to know that
yes this is his responsibility but he's
still not the bad guy in the situation
yeah despite the deaths that are coming
from the situation he's pushing him to
do the right thing and then even by the
end he still follows him on the track
to
[Music]
that police
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was it was great
and um
they had some shots in here that i have
never seen before
that one shot where that zombie is
charging at them and the camera's behind
them and and then it just runs into the
horse yeah i have never seen anything
like that yeah that was visceral i i i
it was i had to just
how did they do that yeah because
that looked like stunt work yeah it
looked like you you must have gotten the
cameraman into a padded suit and just
told him to hold on tight you know yeah
and then the dude just ran into a horse
that's how it looked
uh i know it's not
but it was still very impressive and
i've never seen anything like that
before yeah likewise so
yeah and uh
this was cool it was cool john what'd
you think about the fight at the in the
smoke you know good foggy smokey
stealthy fighting good stealth
outnumbered well i thought they did a
nice job of that too because you know
you've got them running off into the
woods and i
even though you get what's going on you
get that they're trying to throw them
off and they're trying to evade and hide
i really like the way that that was
orchestrated in the way in which he is
actually able to use their
instruments and their signals against
them
and uh and i mean that whole thing was
really tense starting out with when
they're actually in the you know
compound and they're first breaking in
and you've got you know uh young shin
sort of revealing
his uh you know marksmanship
and uh it was just so harrowing because
it's it's cool in some ways and tense in
a way that you know you've got figures
in the fog and like there's an
innate badassness to that imagery but
then you also have the huge
sacrifice of like or the or the setback
of like man we made it through and we're
doing all right and we have this triumph
and now it's being robbed by this new
political [ __ ] yeah exactly and you
know the people breaking through
and and
it's funny because we just watched an
episode of supernatural that had an
element of this but it was in a really
like
uh uh in a much more immediate way it's
like yeah all this work that the crown
prince did to help and save these people
is now right in front of his eyes being
undone as they slaughter them all to get
to him
and and yeah they're really
great at keeping the stakes going
and dividing it up between the very
immediate very simple but obviously very
uh effective zombie work and then the
more complicated
human motivations and political
motivations and all that and now you've
got this one guy who is blindly just
sort of you know he he decapitated my
son i'm gonna do everything i can to
make him suffer and uh i'm
very uh excited and afraid to watch
those two trains ultimately collide
because i have to imagine that at some
point there's going to be a
direct confrontation
between him and the crown prince of some
variety
yeah yeah and yeah too i mean having
them finally i like that was a big turn
i wasn't necessarily expecting and this
one was to have him then reveal to the
other elders
here's your king
his is he he's up and around so
are you gonna oppose him
this is a horrible like manipulation
there well this episode really
establishes too that he's really the one
calling the shots yeah he's the real
king it's like that his daughter has no
power over him yeah don't get don't get
carried away in the position i put you
in yeah yeah
it's sadistic and it brings us some
interesting questions though of
but they don't treat the other zombies
like they're alive yeah they don't seem
to care whatsoever they seem to ignore
even the problem of that kind of at any
turn there's like bird that kill them
you know obviously
obviously um
cho hawk
he knows that this guy's really dead and
this is just a display
too
uh to say that but but who's gonna speak
up against it yeah exactly yeah
so it's fascinating because
the bad guys and the human like the
human angle
they're
only caring about the political
gain and then we got our prince
character who needs to
ensure that he can have his the the
place at the throne
and uh you know though that he would
care about the zombie problem yeah just
try to save the people and help the
people and it just seems like they don't
give a [ __ ] back home they're so
detached from anything that matters to
the people they actually rule they don't
even talk about it they don't even like
discuss that this is such a problem
and i'm like this is going to be a
problem for you you know that made that
stuff on the boat kind of gratifying
because yeah they're sitting there being
like you know they're sitting and eating
and spitting and they're just like ah
you know
what are we gonna do when we get back uh
you know we've got stuff to do and then
all of a sudden yeah that one woman's
got the the remains of her son on the
ship and then you know i like her
yeah that was really that's like ah yes
that's clever and i i wonder because
there were a few shots after that where
you see the ship just kind of listlessly
drifting then and we got that one guy
who probably will will follow he's
probably alone on his journey yeah yeah
the dude who's into the nurse mm-hmm
the funny guy the funny guy
oh yeah
we didn't get much of him in this
episode
no he ran out jumped off the boat yeah
he's probably just stranded somewhere
he's probably just unless yeah
maybe there will be more water zombies
in the next one for him to deal with
next time we see him he's gonna be like
a changed man yeah he's kind of bullets
strapped around yeah salt right leaves
ripped off arms buff and glistening in
the moonlight
it's like 10 zombie heads here
yeah this is a necklace of zombie heads
it's gonna be good i'm rooting for him
to have a character arc and get rid of
his gonorrhea while he's at it oh yeah
that shot too like that aerial shot of
the shot the gonorrhoea of the [ __ ]
that aerial shot of his penis with the
gonorrhoea just
flying through zombies
yeah
and then i mean i i really like
that you know it's a very simple twist
on zombie mythology but i really like
what they've done with it that this side
yeah this sort of supe it's almost like
zombie meets vampire and that it's it
has like a supernatural fringe to it
where it's like it's it's got to do with
the sun cycles and everything and they
just kind of disappear and hide and they
have this almost like ritualistic
quality to them and then when the sun
comes back they're just full-on rabid or
when the the sun goes down again they're
just full on rabid well it helps
separate your plot lines yeah like
during the day you're dealing with the
politics yeah and during the night it's
like all right everyone we gotta be able
to stay alive
try not to die
and i think that separation really helps
yeah because if it all intersected all
the time it would be like way over guys
caught the politics [ __ ] you got way
bigger things to concern yourselves with
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah there it's
proportioned in the way where you think
that for the right reasons yeah for the
wrong reasons
it's good shiz but guys yeah it was a
solid episode another solid episode
they've all been so good yeah every
single one they keep progressing so
strong
and yep got hints of uh the
the young shin guy with his [ __ ]
badass background it's not just he's a
not just a an awesome
secret badass he is secret badass with
the past yeah ooh i can't wait i can't
wait for maybe a flashback or two yeah
let's do a whole episode penultimate one
of those ones one guy nothing to zombies
today just completely focus on his
backstory oh netflix asked us to add
another episode i wonder which one it
was
the one that has nothing to do with the
rest of the plot
but guys leave your thoughts down below
thank you so much for being here the
show has been an absolute pleasure i
want you to go ahead and make sure to
hit that like button if you haven't done
so already
hey let's do
pandemic jones look this is a zombie
show so you're perfect for shouting you
out here
because
if there's anyone who could start a
pandemic
it would be you pj not only would it be
completely apt
considering what the p and pj stands for
but i imagine you could start all kinds
of different pandemics
from the flus
to the leprosy to the zombies but i feel
like you might even get a little bit
creative
i think you might be able to create
the
zit on testicle pandemic
that's right i've thought extensively
about this before the camera ruled
everywhere around the world people got
to get vaccinated because they keep
getting zits on their testicles
and women are getting zits on their
chests making it confusing thinking they
got a third nippity nip
now pandemic jones you got a sick sense
of humor i see you kind of being like
the devil of the
of the pandemics you decide
what
disease you want to spread throughout
the world
and for some reason you almost it tits
so
i'm sorry for
why you do this you are
you are trickster in so many ways you're
a mischievous ghost maker
zit tits and that's why we like you
uh-huh
oh and also you know uh thank you for
being here it's thanksgiving and yeah
yeah yeah but let's
let's not forget about spreading the zit
to disease
but we'll need a fancy name for it
the zt disease
zt disease oh you got you got the zt you
got the ztd yeah oh quarantine you
and give a little pop
[Music]